bonjour on vous retrouve en direct de
Washington en revanche il y a pas de
communiquer de la Maison Blanche est-ce
que c'est surprenant
surprenant oui et non dans le dossier
ukrainien la posture américaine est
assez claire dans le fond Joe Biden
assume totalement un soutien financier
et militaire à un pays agressé est-il ne
serait-ce que nécessaire de le répéter
mais réfutent totalment la
cobelligérance et c'est bien pour cette
raison que la communication de la Maison
Blanche est toujours prudente à
commenter les nouveaux développements
sur le champ de bataille cela ne
signifie pas que Joe Biden n'évoquera
pas cet épisode à Kiev même si Anthony
blinken s'en est chargé comme vous
l'avez dit ces dernières minutes mais il
ne souhaite pas être le premier à réagir
tout simplement rappelez-vous il y a
quelques jours seulement le président
américain a évoqué l'hypothèse de
l'apocalypse nucléaire en rappelant que
l'emploi de ces armes par Moscou était
une option crédible les termes choisis
par le président ont immédiatement été
jugé par ses conseillers comme
inappropriés on a assisté d'ailleurs un
rétropédalage un peu poussif des
communicants de la Maison Blanche dans
les heures qui ont suivi la déclaration
et donc dans le climat actuel la
communication du Président se limite
globalement à annoncer le montant des
aides militaires on l'a dit concrètement
c'est frappes sur Kiev seront condamnés
par Joe Biden dès qu'il en aura
l'occasion mais qui est a déjà été
frappé par le passé même si c'est
frappes sont absolument majeures les
armes utilisées ne sont pas les armes
redoutées par Washington on pensait
évidemment à ses missiles nucléaires
tactiques et donc pour toutes ces
raisons Washington laisse volontiers la
priorité des réactions aux autres
acteurs de la crise dans les prochaines
heures Joe Biden poursuivra le dossier
qui le mobilise tout particulièrement en
ce moment la campagne démocrate pour les
élections de mi-mandat tout simplement
celle de novembre prochain on peut
s'attendre néanmoins à ce que le
président américain au cours d'une de
ces prises de parole répondent à une
question sur le dossier ukrainien ou
prennent tout simplement l'initiative
d'en parler
à suivre